What does 87 cents have to do with a
multimillion euro election campaign?
And how come this neo-Nazi party is
getting funding from the German state?!
It's all to do with the way political
parties are financed in Germany.
The general principles of this party
regulation and financial regulation,
I think they are fair, or at least they are
well intended. But we have seen in the past
that there have been many loopholes and
that the system could be manipulated.
In Germany, there's no limit on how much
parties can spend on election campaigning.
But some parties have more to spend than others.
Here is how the disparity looked at
the last federal election in 2017.
You can clearly see – the two biggest
parties, the Christian Democrats and
the Social Democrats – spent at least
triple the amount of the smaller parties.
These are the key sources of funding
for German political parties:
membership fees; fees paid by MPs; donations;
and "other" sources like sponsoring, assets,
shares, publications and events; and
then there's the big one – state funding.
This system is supposed to
make party financing fair,
transparent and give parties equal
opportunity – and this is how it works:
The more votes a party gets,
the more public money it gets.
Public support is measured by three things:
votes, membership fees and donations.
For every vote a party gets, it
also gets €0.87 from the state.
For the first four million votes, the figure
is even a little more: €1.06 Euros per vote.
Then, for every euro a party gets in membership
fees, it also gets €0.45 from the state.
This 45-cents-per-euro rule also applies for
personal donations - donations from
people, not the ones from companies.
But there are regulations: you can
only get these 45 cents for donations
up to €3,300 per person, per year.
And there is a limit for the total
amount of state financing. In 2021,
this limit was set at €200,049,468.
Smaller parties benefit from this system too.
They might have fewer supporters, but they still
collect votes, membership fees and donations – and
according to what we've just learned, this means:
They get the money from the state.
Here's an example:
Last year, the neo-Nazi party NPD got
€370,632.85 from the German state.
It's a very small amount compared to what
the larger parties are getting – but a lot
of Germans aren't happy about it. Because the
NPD has been ruled as anti-constitutional.
There is a push to stop
public money going to the NPD.
The government has asked the
country's top court to stop
state funding flowing to the extreme right.
But the court doesn't seem to be in a big
hurry. That was in 2019, and we're
still waiting for the verdict.
That's one problem in the system –
but critics highlight other loopholes.
There's a lack of transparency. There
is no limit to financial influence.
For example, donations to political
parties, there's no legal maximum.
Indeed: In Germany, there's no limit on
the amount parties can accept in donations.
To understand it better, let's have a look at
the details: There are different transparency
rules for small, medium and large donations.
Donations under €500 can stay anonymous.
If donations are more than €10,000, parties
have to publicly declare where they came from.
They do this in their annual reports.
The problem here, however, is that the
reports usually appear with a very
long delay - of one to two years.
Only donations over €50,000
have to be declared immediately.
Another loophole in the system has to do with
these guys here and plenty of other industry
players and business representatives.
Instead of making large donations, big
companies often "sponsor" party events instead.
For example, a car manufacturer displaying
products at a party conference – where
they can also network with politicians.
Sponsoring doesn't have to be declared
in the party's financial reports.
And this is really annoying. And from my
perspective, that sponsoring activity is still
buried in this income from other
activities category in the annual
reports of parties. And that means it is
invisible, put differently: untransparent.
That brings us to another issue – the authority
that's supposed to check if parties are
sticking to the rules – and fine them if not.
Critics say that body is not fit for purpose.
For example, it cannot
proactively investigate parties.
And it's also under the control
of the Bundestag president,
who belongs to a political party
himself. In the current government,
the president of the Bundestag is a member
of Angela Merkel's Christian Democrats.
So there's potential for conflict of interest.
Well, what we need is simply ameliorating the
system as it is, rendering the supervisory
body more independent from politics, and
recognizing that donations, at least above
€10,000, can really make an impact. And so
rendering a donors identity
transparent immediately.
A look at the details makes it
clear: There ARE many loopholes
in the system - and experts say addressing
these would make party financing fairer.
Right now what matters to parties –
and their bank accounts – is getting
as many votes as possible on September
26. Because the cents really do add up.